[Music]
even when will and Kate came over and I
had met her for the first time like I
was a hugger I've always been a hugger I
didn't realize that that is really a
jarring for a lot of Brits another day
another controversy from Prince Harry
and Meghan markle's docu-series this
seems to be an attempt to take down the
royal family
et's learning even if the hug wasn't
jarring for William and Kate that might
describe the Royal Family's overall
response to Netflix's Harry and Megan I
think if Harry and Megan are going to
continue to tarnish some might even say
trash the reputation of the monarchine
that's a problem for the monarchy while
there's no shortage of Jabs at
Buckingham Palace I was being fed to the
Wolves William and Kate's Inner Circle
takes issue with one moment in
particular when Megan recalls the first
time she met the Princess of Wales even
when will and Kate came over and I had
met her for the first time they came
over for dinner I remember I was in
ripped jeans and I was barefoot
it's like I was a hugger I've always
been a hugger I didn't realize that that
is really
jarring for a lot of Brits but now a
source close to the family offers a
second opinion calling Kate very warm
and someone who shows affection all the
time I didn't realize that that is
really a jarring for a lot of Brits as
for the hug well The Insider explains to
E.T that Kate hugs people but everyone
is more reserved with someone they've
never met previously I think our
suspicions about this being a pretty
cool relationship right from the start
have have been confirmed here and I
think it also confirms what we've always
known which is that Megan and Kate are
two very very different women you know
that's why they were never going to be
best friends yeah when it comes to the
docu-series there's plenty of candid
moments Beyonce just texted
really much
but there's just as many throwing shade
at the Royals
it was terrifying to have my brother
Scream and Shout out to me and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in adding more
fuel to the fire this disclaimer stating
members of the royal family declined to
comment
you are making me scared but the hearsay
continues and a different Source close
to the Royals tells ET that's incorrect
quote neither Buckingham Palace nor
Kensington Palace nor any members of the
royal family were approached for comment
on the content of the series
[Music]
thank you